you need a righteous life I think I do
yeah do you yeah and you boasted openly
of having six seven Partners at once so
is that righteous there's no moral View
From Me simply asking you what you think
righteous means I think righteous is
living true to your heart and knowing
that you're doing good by people not
snaking anybody not lying to anybody I
know I live a very righteous life
you've ever been in love yeah how many
times uh plenty I believe in love
between men and women I'm a real love
you know yeah I believe how many times
would you say enough I believe men and
women are a beautiful Union I think
we're slightly different but when we
work together with the most powerful
force in the world how many women have
you loved
I don't know pierce my few give me a
Bullpup 5 10 20. let's let's say you
don't forget how many people you've been
in love with let's say 10 I mean I've
been in love and I certainly believe
that men and women when they work
together it's the most beautiful force
on the planet I believe in family I
believe in children I believe in if you
believe in family and children and love
yeah why are you single I'm not single
well you're not married so I mean well
if I was married the last thing I would
do is advertise it to the feral
Psychopaths on the internet so I'm not
feral psyched about well like you call
me a friend earlier it can be debated
peers but the point the point but the
point I'm making as a whole is that all
of these do you want to get married to
the point no but let's let's please for
example let's please for a second
because you've interrupted me so many
times I've failed well actually I've
only interrupted you just be clear when
you've actually answered a different
question cool well then on all these
points and you've admitted that on all
these points you're making on repeat
you're making you're taking these
sentences and on repeat you're using to
what you're weaponizing them against me
I'm not weaponizing anything okay it's
fine no no the more weaponizing the
weaponizing that doesn't exist no
problem but you said to me come on bring
it on read out all the things that you
think of blatant misogyny all I've done
is literally read out all the things we
identified from all the research that I
thought were blatantly misogynist and
giving you the chance to respond and the
only type I've interrupted you is when
you've tried to answer a completely
different question understood peers
the but these things were said in large
context where often I'm talking about
how
for example on the same podcast where
you've read one of them sentences from I
was talking about how it's a man's duty
to die by a woman and the guy asked me
said if 10 men if 10 men with knives
attacked your woman wouldn't you just I
said yeah I'd stand and die I'd never
just run away because I have a duty as a
man I must I must die on the spot to
protect her honor and my honor I'm
talking about a man having
responsibility to his duties I'm talking
about the old traditional ways of
masculinity and what happens is a few
sentences from such a long conversation
is taken and used against I understand
that so I want you to understand that
I'm talking about protecting and
providing for women I'm talking about a
man-making do you want to get married no
but this is but we have to we household
feed into each other peers I'm talking
about protect the whole question no but
I'm talking about protecting and
providing for a woman I'm talking about
a man being responsible for her safety I
understand so of course I believe in men
and women of course I believe in love of
course I believe in marriage of course I
believe in family the idea that I don't
believe in the idea that I don't believe
in these things I didn't trust you if
you believed it I asked you if you're
going to get married one day absolutely
you'd like to if I'm not married already
I would I will be married one day if I'm
not well you might be secretly married I
I could be married correct why would you
not tell me either way why would I
advertise to the feral Psychopaths of
the world who have tried their very best
to destroy me for an opinion about my
private life and the things that are
most sacred to me why do you think if
you said you were married if I would
hate you I don't know but people hate me
it's about me understanding that I'm a
hard target but I am very very
protective of the people I care about
right but you believe in the concept of
marriage completely that's what we were
talking about the whole time what do you
think we talked about a man giving a
woman away I believe in marriage more
than anybody I believe in marriage and
no please I believe in marriage in the
traditional sense I believe a man has a
duty to stand up and be a real man I
believe that the problem with the world
today that we are facing is that not
enough men are sticking to the age-old
ways of masculinity I believe that me
standing up and saying a man must
protect a woman and provide for her so
he needs to make sure that she's safe he
needs a degree of authority I have no
problem with no but no you but people do
have a problem with it and that's not
sorry and that's the world we're in now